you know I've gotten a lot of emails
over the last month or so from people
saying David sir I hear it vaguely
mentioned that the Republican party is
now more extreme than ever but is that
true is it true that the Republican
party has actually moved to the right
and particularly in the context of
looking at people like Marjorie Taylor
green and Lauren bobert and similar
extremist lunatics in the Republican
party it's reasonable to ask has it
always been like this and the truth is
that it has not this is not a segment
about how great the Republican party
used to be this is a segment about how
much less extreme the Republican party
used to be for those who don't know the
history the Republican party was once a
relatively moderate political force in
the United States compared to where they
are today over the last 40 years there
has been a radical transformation in the
Republican party where it has become
more and more extreme in its views and
its policies in its rhetoric and in the
level of extremism that it is willing to
accept within its ranks again I might
have to say this 20 times I'm not
rehabilitating the old Republican Party
I'm comparing what it used to be to what
it is today and one of the most glaring
sort of examples of this shift has been
the party's view on social issues in the
70s and 80s there were many elements of
the Republican party that were generally
and and sort of superficially at least
supportive of abortion rights and of gay
rights but we know that that has changed
dramatically and it is a party that has
won many elections and raised a ton of
money being completely against abortion
and completely against LGBT rights if
you go to the 70s and 80s you can find
that abortion rights and LGBT rights
were simply not as partisan as uh we're
not partisan issues to the degree that
they are today and you had some
Republicans that were actually
supportive of those causes if you look
at president Richard Nixon one of the
first politicians to publicly support
abortion rights in a 69 speech he said
this should be a decision made by a
woman and her doctor not the government
that's the small government position on
abortion in 72 the Republican Party
platform included a plank supporting
abortion rights to some degree they
maintained that for four years and in
1976 the Republican Party became
significantly more anti-abortion uh you
go to 1977.
a republican-led Congress passed a bill
known as the gay rights Bill and it
banned discrimination on the basis of
sexual orientation in the federal
government and in Washington D.C that
was a republican-led congress at the
time you then look at
um Ronald Reagan in 86 when Reagan
signed the immigration reform and
Control Act it actually provided some
legal protections for Gay and Lesbian
immigrants to the United States in 87
the Republican Party platform included
language supporting anti-discrimination
measures for Gay and Lesbian Americans
so it's not that those views necessarily
reflected the views of the entire
Republican party at those points in time
but there used to be support at least to
some degree for those causes among
Republicans in the 70s and 80s that's
social issues taxation
in the past Republicans were open to the
idea that we might raise taxes if it
meant funding important programs or if
it would reduce the deficit today they
never even acknowledge that uh uh
increasing taxes to fund certain
programs can actually reduce the deficit
by being economically stimulative they
pretend that that's not an economic
reality anymore and we know the result
it's led to the erosion of so many
different social programs immigration is
an area where the views of the
Republicans have changed quite
dramatically in the past Republicans
were often supportive of immigration
side as a source of economic growth
sort of we're okay with the cultural
diversity component of it as well but
now we've seen the Republican Party
become obsessed with building a border
wall cracking down on immigration saying
we shouldn't even provide a path to
citizenship to people who were brought
here as kids by their parents through no
fault of their own but when you go back
to 86 I mentioned that Immigration
Reform Act that President Reagan signed
it provided amnesty to millions of
undocumented immigrants already living
in the United States and Reagan said at
the time quote the legalization
Provisions in this act will go far to
improve the lives of a class of
individuals who now must hide in the
shadows without access to many of the
benefits of a free and open society that
was Reagan who said that John McCain in
2005 co-sponsored the comprehensive
Immigration Reform Act which would have
provided a path to citizenship for
undocumented immigrants Mitt Romney as
recently as 2012 expressed support for
comprehensive immigration reform which
would have given a path to citizenship
for some undocumented immigrants so this
has been a change a climate change I'll
mention briefly
you had a time in the past
when Republicans were open to talking
about what actions should we take to
address the issue of climate change they
didn't necessarily agree with Democrats
on what those actions actions should be
but they agreed on the science they
didn't question the science you now have
much of the Republican party that just
says oh no the science is completely
wrong so the Republican parties shift to
the extreme right is very real it's been
extraordinarily impactful because it has
influenced media coverage of a lot of
these issues media coverage has
influenced public opinion on a lot of
these issues but the Republican party
has moved dramatically to the extreme
and I don't know at this point What's
going to turn it around let me know your
thoughts leave a comment send an email
to info davidpackman.com